هل تعتقدون أن بوتين يحظى بدعم أكثر أو أقل
داخل روسيا الآن منذ
نظرة وفاة باغوسيان أود أن أقول إن النتيجة ذات
شقين من وجهة نظر
نخب البيروقراطية الحاكمة وهو أمر
في غاية الأهمية أه في
دولة استبدادية
موقف بوتين  أه تحسنت بشكل كبير
أه سأخبرك بكل
النخب الروسية اليوم الآن يرون أن بوتين
لا يزال قادرًا على السيطرة على
الميدان لذا لنقول مثل إذا تسبب شخص ما في
مشكلة أه
لن يعيش لفترة طويلة لأنك
تعلم ل  هذين الشهرين اللذين
مرا
منذ لحظة تمرد ما قبل التمرد
حتى مات وكأنه بدا أن
عالم السياسة الروسية بأكمله
اهتز وكأنه يبدو أنك يمكن أن
تسبب مشاكل في وضعها وما زلت تشعر
بأن الانحدار كان على
ما يرام لقد كان أه  تعرف حصل على
مشاريع جديدة أه حصل على تمويل من
الحكومة
كل التحقيقات الجنائية ضده
أوقفت كل الأموال
المصادرة منه أه استعادها
فبدا أن قواعد الألعاب
تغيرت يمكنك أن تتصرف بمفردك
دون  الاهتمام ببوتين وأه والآن
انتهى الأمر الآن سيرى كل الروس
أنه لا أه الرسالة واضحة بوتين
يقول مثل الرجل لا تظن أنك إذا
تسببت في مشكلة ستشعر بخير
لعامة الناس الأمر مختلف فهم
يهتمون بـ  من الناحية الجمالية، فإن القول بأنه
لا ينبغي القيام به فحسب، بل ينبغي
القيام به بشكل جيد
ومقنع، وأنت تعرف أن ما
صنعه بوتين لا يبدو جميلًا،
ولا يعجبك، كما تعلم أنه ليس
سلوكًا ليليًا، لذا فإن القول الاحترازي كان بمثابة التصرف
في العلن  لقد كان يتصرف بشكل علني، وما
فعله بورين كان شيئًا يشبه
السجن، وهو نوع من الخيانة، لقد صعد
إلى الخلف،
لذلك من وجهة نظر
صورة بوتين، لم يكن الأمر لطيفًا، فقد
فاز على جانب وخسر على
الجانب الآخر.